So anyway,
since that time I've,
I've gone after many different things.
Um,
peanut pop off the evangelists said he was getting the word of God.
Randy came to Houston in 1986 the guy that had the earpiece in.
Yeah,
I found the earpiece.
Oh,
you found that was me.
Yeah.
So Randy was writing an article,
I think it was a hustler magazine.
It was one of those magazines on evangelists.
Angela.
So it was a good place to hide something.
It was one of those things.
It may not have been hostile.
I,
so I don't want you to quote me on that.
Then the house did a lot of those and that's what I'm saying.
I might have been penthouse,
but I don't think it plays a lot.
I think it was hustling,
but I could be wrong is one of the ones that people actually read.
Cause the girls never take their panties off.
So you get bored with just looking at what they do now though.
Didn't they go back to,
well they don't know they were,
they went [inaudible] all,
they did not do that at all.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Show amazing will power.
Sorry.
Yay.
Um,
went to like bikinis or underwear.
They stopped taking their clothes off,
but then sales inexplicably tank.
So strange.
There's articles.
Great.
They did have good articles,
did playboy interviews.
They had a lot of groundbreaking on it.
Goes to through the years,
had a book of all the different playboy interviews over the years.
And I was like,
you probably have some good stuff.
Yeah.
So Randy,
yeah.
Randy.
Yeah.
Writing for us law on an evangelist.
He said,
Hey,
do you want to come see this Sif Angeles with me?
I'm like,
yeah,
sure,
I'll come.
So went there and um,
it's about 10,000 feet.
What's downtown?
Big Auditory.
And he was a huge auditorium.
You know,
all these people sitting around and a pop off comes out on stage.
He starts saying he's getting the word of God.
He's telling people their names,
information,
who their doctors are,
what their ailments are.
And he's,
he started healing.
People have cancer.
He starts healing people live blindness.
People walk in again.
And it was really,
really emotional for me.
I tears in my eyes,
but I knew that it was all bullshit,
but I had to news bullshit and he's still crying.
It get you get this whole fucking life.
Like when you see a little kid crying and running down the aisle,
you know you,
you want to get angry,
but at the same time it's like,
it's just so emotional.
It's just you get caught up in this whole thing.
He just do.
So he asked for people to collect money.
He's just asking random people to come up,
grab a bucket,
go collect money.
I got down there,
I mean when I was like the 15th bucket,
I got my bucket.
I walk around,
I get checks.
I got probably an album,
I don't know how much,
10 grand,
20 grand,
I don't know.
You know what I've got,
I mean money.
First of all,
getting money.
Then you've got to go.
I'm thinking I'm done.
He said,
nope.
Yeah,
okay.
Once you got to go back out and collect checks and how are we going out getting
checks in the bucket.
Then it's like go out,
get sealed offerings and people were dropping envelopes in there with like
watches,
rings and stuff like that.
As I come back,
I hand the bucket up to pop off and I look up and I noticed that he's got a
piece of plastic in his ear.
I go back to Randy and I say,
Randy,
I said,
look,
either this man of God,
God doesn't like him enough to heal him and he's got a hearing aid or something
else is going on.
I don't know what,
but something else is going on and I think that's how he's getting information
and Randy was like,
no,
he's using the Marnix.
Mnemonics are basically memory systems.
All right.
I you,
I have to use a lot of mnemonics to memorize things because otherwise I have
major issues and I know a lot about mnemonics.
You either memorize a lot about things,
about a few things or you memorize a few things about a lot of things,
but you don't memorize a lot of things about a lot of things.
And he was memorizing a lot of things about a lot of things.
If that was the case,
I said,
I don't think so.
So they went out to the next pet,
pop off a congregation thing,
which was in San Francisco,
got a friend of Al's,
uh,
from uh,
Alec,
Jason,
I think his name is,
uh,
from uh,
who was an electronics engineer and that was everything about electronics.
And he brought this little scanner and dressed up as a security guard hanging
out in the back.
And he was scared to death.
He was going to get called.
Nobody questioned him.
He's there in a security outfit and he scans all the frequencies ahead of time
and he blocks out every one of those frequencies that are known frequencies.
The moment pop off,
hits the stage,
a brand new frequency pops up and turns out,
I think it was a 37 point.
I can tell you in just a second here.
It was a,
yeah.
Was that the frequency that he was on was yeah,
I thought it was right.
Yeah.
39.7 megahertz.
That's what God broadcasts on.
And it sounds an awful lot like Peter Popoff offs wife.
So what we did was we taped all this and went to the Johnny Carson show.
This is how long ago that was now on the tonight show with Johnny Carson.
Randy takes it on the tonight show and keep in mind that,
um,
pop off with tape every single one of his shows and sort of edit it real time as
well.
You put them on television.
Yeah.
He would put them all on television.
The Sallie Mae,
you know,
tons of,
I mean,
they were,
they had a,
a monthly budget,
I think it was like $550,000 every single month.
You know,
that's,
yeah.
That,
that,
that was a working budget,
that that's not the money they were actually making.
So God knows how much that's how much they were spending.
That's how much they were spending.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So how would a dirty business,
yeah,
it's so dirty.
It's so dirty to just lie to people like that.
I would make a great evangelists if I wasn't ethical.
There are times like,
Oh God,
you know,
but I just couldn't do it.
I couldn't do it.
So on the tonight show,
they play,
they play the footage that they have from his TV show,
they play all that and then they,
oh,
and this was the one time that Johnny always wanted to know everything that was
going to happen.
They,
she didn't want any surprises,
but his staff said,
no,
you want to be surprised by this.
Trust us.
So sure enough,
they play that footage and then they play the footage with pop offs wife and
she's saying things like PD.
The first thing she says,
PD,
nod your head if you can hear me because if you don't,
we're going to have trouble tonight.
He nods his head as he's talking,
you know,
doing this whole event gelical thing.
Um,
and uh,
then she started saying,
oh,
there's a live one up in the back.
She's got cancer in her breast and make her run up and down the island,
shake those breasts.
You know,
it's just all these like re and there's a lot of nasty stuff.
Some of that stuff we couldn't play on this night show,
but we showed enough.
And so just a disdain the marketing of these people.
She actually had breast cancer and she's telling her that,
yeah,
these people do these.
It's a real ailments that all these people,
well,
almost real elements.
I'll get to that in a second.
Um,
cause we sent some stooges in and um,
so yeah,
just nasty,
nasty stuff.
But anyway,
the stuff we showed on the tonight show,
Johnny sits there and he never eaten,
didn't like to edit a shows either,
but he had to edit this because a moment that came on Johnny's like,
Oh shit.
And you couldn't say shit on TV back then.
And so we had to edit that out at that point.
And he says like,
do they know about this?
And like,
nope,
they do now.
And at first pop off,
try to say that we,
we,
uh,
we hired actors to be his wife and then when it was obvious that we didn't,
he then came out and says,
I thought everybody knew that.
I use that to enhance the word of God.
And it took a long time for him to go on to that.
Here's the,
here's the crappy thing about this,
right when I was there,
he's doing stuff like telling people to throw their medications up on stage.
You don't need them.
God's going to take care of,
you know,
imagine somebody throws up some digitalis bills or something they really,
truly need and think God's going to heal them.
So people do die from these things.
And he was using a lot of other tricks like,
oh,
I'm,
part of the way he was getting the information was this,
right?
So people fill out prayer cards ahead of time and they put them in these boxes
in the back of the room when nobody's really paying attention,
the boxes get switched out.
So all those prayer cards with all this information goes backstage to the wife
and she's able to send that information to him.
Another thing,
she would come out on staff,
she would come out,
people come to these things to hours and hours ahead of time,
like literally,
and they leave the hospital on carts and everything else.
And she would walk out,
she'd say,
Hi Mrs Pop,
off we go.
I hope my husband gets to you tonight.
You know,
where are you from?
Oh,
that's nice.
Why?
What's wrong with it?
Oh,
I'm so,
we'll all pray for you.
And she gets all this information again.
She'd go back,
she had a big tape recorder in her purse and she would write that information
down.
Another one was what I call like the Kathryn Kuhlman trick.
Uh,
and Catherine Coleman was an evangelist way,
way back,
who had all these great,
great little like scam trick things.
And what they do is they wait for somebody to come walk in with a cane and then
they can walk but not well.
And they're using a cane.
They walk up to them and say,
you know,
what?
Wouldn't you be much more comfortable in a wheelchair?
And we put you up right up front,
you'll be right next to the reverend,
who's gonna say no to that.
So they get pushed up in the wheelchair.
And as I push him along,
they said,
where are you from?
Who's your doctor?
You know what's wrong with you getting all this information?
Go back out,
write the information down and give it misses pop off.
So the wheelchair sitting there,
reverend comes out.
At some point,
he can look at that person and he said,
so name.
And he says,
we've never talked before.
We'd never met before,
have we?
Because they haven't.
It was the usher that was pushing him down.
The guy that didn't fall,
he says,
you know,
God says you can be healed now.
God said,
I'm getting from God that you can't walk.
Is that right?
And the guy is sitting there,
he's thinking,
this is a man of God,
right?
So I'm not contradicting him.
And he must mean everybody at a walk properly.
Again,
that's what he's saying.
He's saying that my doctor says I can never walk properly again.
So he doesn't contradict him.
He says,
I say,
you can.
God says you can stand up.
The man stands up.
Well,
that's your first miracle because everybody else,
their perception is this guy's in that wheelchair cannot walk.
He says,
take a few steps.
Got It.
Takes a few steps.
He got that beat.
It's war,
right?
So now you've got the emotion going even more,
because here's a man that couldn't even walk.
He stood and now he walked pop off,
then goes and gets in the wheelchair and sits in it.
He says,
walk to the back of the wheelchair and the guy hobbles to the back of the
wheelchair,
he says,
pushed me,
and the guy pushes them.
Real miracle,
right?
But think about it.
That wheelchair is now acting like a fricking Walker,
you know?
And then the great climax of the whole piece of this trick is he takes her
wheelchair,
puts it back where it is,
and he says to him,
now that's your wheelchair.
Meaning Joe,
like if you got up right now,
walked across the room and say,
Hey Joe,
that's your chair.
You'd say,
yes.
Well,
it actually is your chair.
You own it.
But I mean,
in normal circumstances I say you were in my studio,
you'd go,
yes.
It doesn't mean it's your chair,
it just means it's where you're sitting in that moment,
right?
So the person sits down and you've seen this whole miracle.
So he's got all these tricks like that,
the old trick of one leg longer than the other,
and you make them both the same size.
Also,
people get caught up in the moment and they're on television.
They want it to be real and the they get,
I think that's in emotion.
That's a lot of things.
Um,
but I don't think so.
In this case,
I think this is more of a religious thing that people truly believe.
And when you have,
it's like when I was talking in tongues,
when I was yelling,
you know,
I've got all this stuff,
me and I got all this adrenaline flowing through my body.
You get caught up in it.
It's like when I was watching it,
you know,
I'm getting caught off.
I'm having all this reaction to my body despite the fact.
I know it's all bullshit.
I'm still having this,
this entire reaction.
You know,
it's,
you know,
mediums I,
to me,
the worst scum out there right now are the mediums.
And why did I say that?
Because they're taking advantage of a person in a vulnerable moment in their
life and they're doing it for that long game.
They're also doing it for money.
And a lot of people will say,
well,
they're making them feel good.
You know what?
I can give crack to a junkie.
It doesn't mean it's good for him,
right.
The grieving process is a natural part of the state that you have to go through
to stay with the living.
We had a very good friend whose son died of cancer,
10 years old,
died of cancer.
She's understanding,
understandably,
has this huge gaping hole,
right as huge gaping hole,
which she's just feeling sad.
She's upset,
she needs to fill it with something.
Normally you turned to your family for those things,
but she met,
she met a a medium who convinced the she could talk to her dead son.
So she stopped talking to her two living daughters.
She stopped talking to her husband,
she started talking to the meat,
even talking to her,
her dead son almost ended up with a divorce,
almost lost her entire life as a result,
and this happens all the time and it is so,
so sad and dirty people,
very dirty people.
Long Island,
medium.
You Ever Watch Hotel Theresa Caputo?
Yeah,
and the worst part is the networks at edit the stuff to make it look even
better.
If they don't give a fuck up,
just trying to make money.
It just trying to make money.
They that,
that's all.
They don't care about this being,
they somehow or another feel like they're not a part of the scam.
I mean they're,
they're literally committing fraud.
They aren't there.
No,
I agree.
They're,
they're perpetrating the fraud.
Well,
the network's not involved with what it is,
is a production company.
The production company is bringing it to the network,
but the network should know the process and put it on,
knows what's going on.
They know it's bullshit,
but it's like,
you know what?
I was going to get ratings.
It's going to do this.
Let's promote it.
Let's push it.
You know,
they shouldn't walk on set Onsi Fi and the network.
They didn't want me just debunking everything.
Nope.
And I had to tell them,
I said,
the problem is everything's bullshit.
Yeah.
It's not that I'm trying to debunk everything,
we're just really looking at it.
Yeah.
Everything's bullshit.
Way To why in my show I,
I started to go on this a little bit of going on that show telepathy where I
talk about telepathy and what it is and everything else.
But as I'm doing it,
I'm performing and there's a part in that show where I feel really,
really dirty and I feel really,
really bad,
but I feel like I have to do it.
And I actually talked to some people's dead relatives in that show,
and it's like the most despicable,
horrible thing.
And it makes me want to cry every time I do it.
But it's because in the second half of the show I go,
what is telepathy?
Well,
I think I know what it is.
I think it's a,
a,
a subset of magic.
I think it's a form of entertainment and very cruel form of entertainment.
I know I played with emotions.
If you,
any of you here this evening,
but how else can I convince you on an emotional level and on a logical level
that you can do is bullshit.
Because here's the thing,
right?
It's like your friend,
they've had this one experience that's an emotional experience meeting the
psychic and the psychic telling them.
If you tell them,
hey,
well I've got this friend vantage check that could do that same thing for you.
He's going to,
yeah,
but this is,
you know,
or if I do,
I hate to say Ben,
a check is a real scifi tries to meet him and then I do it and he goes,
wow,
that guy's real.
Then now you say it's bullshit.
Now they'll think a little bit and go,
well,
you know what?
I had that same emotional experience.
I had that same feeling.
Maybe,
maybe I'll look at it.
My job,
I feel he's never to break down a person's belief systems,
you know,
you can believe whatever you want,
that's fine.
So long as you're not hurting anybody else,
I'm Kinda sorta okay with it.
But the big thing is,
the problem that I have is with the people that have taken advantage of those
people's beliefs,
cause it's always than sheep's clothing.